monster hunter rise is the latest and
greatest in the monster hunter series
it streamlines some of the pre-existing
systems and adds a gigaton of new
features like new ways to get around
a writable dog friend called a palamoot
a new endemic life form called a wire
bug which increases your mobility in the
world your dexterity and fights and it
adds a new skill for each of the 14
weapon types
but we're here to talk shop on the
tetranodon so let's jump right into it
the tetranodon is based on a water demon
from japanese folklore called a kappa
who in stories loves sumo wrestling
and steals your organs through your butt
in monster hunter rise though the only
thing that tetranodon does to your butt
has beat the hell
out of it but that is bad enough so when
you go up against one you'll need to be
prepared
as they say knowledge is half the battle
so let's study our big fat water
dwelling enemy
tetranodon has two states in the first
smaller milder form it walks around on
four legs so its movement speed is
increased but its size and damage are
smaller compared to its larger form
big t gorges itself on gravel or pond
scum or something when it senses a fight
coming
expanding its size and weight and it
adds a massive increase in damage
each of the forms come with their own
attack patterns or variations so you'll
need to change your approach after your
prey is eaten
when in its natural state the tetronodon
has a straightforward rush attack you'll
need to sideways dodge to avoid the
expanded version of this attack will be
harder to dodge because it cuts a much
wider path the tetranodon can spit water
with its water breath attack in both of
its forms
the super-sized version of this delivers
a single stream of water with increased
damage
this big dude can pick up a boulder and
throw it at you
as soon as you see the tetranodon go for
a rock it's best to stand back
watch its movements and wait for the
toss so you can see where it's going to
land and get out of the way
despite its large size this thing can
move its jump attack will launch the
tatranodon into the air and when it
lands you better not be there
it has a massive area of effect and huge
damage in the expanded form
being based on a sumo wrestling yokai
the tetranodon has a foot slam attack
which shoots out sideways from its body
the large version of this attack causes
tremor but can be dodged
using the wire bug i mentioned before so
how do you prepare your hunter for this
battle
health potions to take the edge off the
damage you're definitely going to take
no buries to remove some of the status
effects like water blight
dung bombs to stun him if he tries to
eat you and possibly some trimmer
resistance to your armor
gathering endemic life can be a massive
help as well the cloth fly can distract
as well as boost your defense
and like many other monsters the
tetranodon is territorial
so use the whale nard to attract other
monsters to provoke a fight which will
be both
entertaining and take some of the
tetranodon's health during the fight
focus on the tatranodon's head front
legs and exposed belly to do the most
damage
once the aquatic demon is defeated you
can use his carpus
hide head disc and beak to create new
armor which increases defense
as well as water and ice resistance or
new weapons that add water
damage to your arsenal of oversized
monster killing devices
monster hunter rises out on nintendo
switch on march 26th
i'll see you in the new rampage mode
shall we go